[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous video i had obtained
this form for the lhs
one so uh i'll start off
on this video by writing the expression
for the lhs2
so let me just go back to that page uh
where i had the
initial expression for this lhs2 i'll
just copy it from here
okay so this is my lhs2
and unlike the lhs1 where i had gone
into
a full-fledged derivation
i won't do it here instead i will just
write down the final expression that i
want that i arrive at
after doing the various
manipulations and that is in this form
so i have the cyclic integral terms just
like i had
the ones in the case of the lhs one
so please note that there is no magic
going on here it's just that i have
written down
the the final expression on a piece of
paper separately
and i'm just copying it from there okay
because
i want to invest the time that is there
in this
in this video lectures uh not on these
repetitive kinds of
derivations rather on some of the more
important and interesting parts of the
derivations all right
okay so this is the part which uh which
comes with the d y
uh in exactly the same fashion that we
were uh
where obtained the part
with the d y earlier and the next one
with the dx
will come with a minus sign please note
that this minus sign is very much
present within this square bracket
but of course outside this uh these
first term
okay so for that we have
[Music]
this
[Music]
okay so these terms that i have just
written down these are basically
my boundary terms okay because you know
that this integration
is over the entire periphery of the
plate under consideration
the next terms that i'm going to write
they will be pertaining to the entire
domain
so we had equivalent terms or
corresponding terms
for the entire domain for the lhs
one also
okay
[Music]
now for our subsequent step uh of course
we are going to write down the rhs
uh let me let me do that first it will
take only a
half a minute so for the rhs
i am concerned with
[Music]
these traction terms
and these uh
for the problem at hand or for the
general situation at hand for our theory
for the sake of our theory is this
the skew is the distributed load uh
as a special case we could consider
point loads also using the direct tilde
functions
anyway so we have this load on the plate
acting in the z direction which is why
this is multiplied by this delta w
the displacement in the z direction and
this integration is over the entire
domain
okay so we have this lhs2 here in the
previous page
what we had this was basically our lhs
one and
uh together if you consider this
lhs and the rhs together you will see
that
uh back back here we have the presence
of these
terms within uh that are that are over
then that domain
okay this integration is over the entire
domain this is from the lhs1
uh in our current page here also we have
from the lhs to these terms which are
over the entire domain
and on the right hand side i have this
term also which is over the entire
domain
now it is these terms which are over the
entire domain
which will which will extract out and
which will contribute
to the governing equations the terms
which are over the
which are under the cyclic integral both
in the lhs2
as well as in the lhs1 if i just go back
there in the hs1 you see that i have the
cyclic integral terms
those are applicable on the boundary or
the periphery
okay so uh
i have to actually go about extracting
all these terms
all right so how do i go about
extracting so the principle is the same
you note that if i go back to this lhs1
considering these terms over the entire
domain you see i have certain terms
which are the coefficients of delta us
we have i have some terms which are the
coefficient of delta vs
and i have certain terms which are the
coefficient of delta w
all right these are the various terms
which are going to contribute to the
governing differential equation
separately it is also important to note
that in the lhs2 in the term involving
the over the entire domain there are no
contributions or there are no
coefficients of delta u s
or delta vs we only have the
contributions
in the form of the coefficient of this
delta w so it is this term which is
going to get
clubbed with this term here because this
is the coefficient of delta w and this
lhs1 and the lhs2 they are going to come
together
but this coefficient here and this
coefficient here they're going to stand
alone okay so first of all i'm going to
extract this
out so what i'm doing is this i am
writing
i am considering lhs1
plus lhs 2 is equal to
rhs
and then i have these entire terms these
huge
terms but from the lhs1 i just have this
term which is the coefficient of delta
s so that alone is going to give me
okay so for my governing differential
equation
okay i will have
that first that that coefficient term
del n x del x let's take a look at that
again
del n x del x plus del n x y del y
that is equal to zero for the next one
let me go back to that page again
let me pick up the coefficient of delta
v s this is del n y del y
plus del n x y del x
so i'll write the nxy term first
please note that there is a certain
niceness
about these equations uh i say niceness
because
this nx
ny and this n x y they are basically
defined
on the basis of uh
of those are the stress terms and uh
you see these seem to be of that very
same form
uh that uh that the stress equilibrium
equations are
from our studies in applied elasticity
so back then we had
del sigma xx del x plus del sigma xy del
y
is equal to 0 at least for the 2d case
and then we had del sigma x y del x
plus delta sigma yy del y and it is
exactly in that form okay of course
these
are integrated terms uh
so there is a certain niceness that's
what i said that
next however it's not going to be so
nice because
uh you see
here i have this huge term in fact it is
so huge that i will not
uh write it and not try to write it like
that rather i'll just copy it from here
okay this is the coefficient of delta w
from
lhs
i'll put it here
so this is the contribution from the
lhs1
and then i'll extract this
i'll extract this part out
now before i do that i'll have to be a
little bit
careful uh
in noting that here although i have
extracted it out
there is a minus sign sitting outside
this integration
it didn't really matter for this term
and this term because they were just
alone
whether i put the minus in front of that
and the minus in front of that
really matter but because i'm going to
club this term with with the coefficient
of the corresponding term uh that is the
coefficient of delta w in the lhs2
that the minus sign really matters okay
so there is a minus sign present here
now let's see here here also we have a
minus sign outside so it's good
okay so yeah so everything has the same
sign
so i'll just copy it here
so this is that entire thing okay
so this part is coming from the nhs 2
and this comes with a plus sign you can
put the bracket here
okay and i'll just adjust it a little
bit because i do have to put the
equal to zero
on the right hand side okay
[Music]
all right now what we're going to do
next
is to try to simplify this third
equation and to do that
uh we are going to uh
utilize the information which is present
in this first equation
and in this second equation and you see
that can be easily done
so i have this del nx
del x over here
then i have del w del x
plus n x
del square w del x square
plus again the same thing over here
del n x y del x
del w del y
plus n x y
l square w del x
del y now dealing with the second one
i have del n y del y
del w del y plus
n y l squared w
del y square plus
from this i have del n
x y del y
del w del x plus
n x y del square w
del y del x so i'm done with these terms
both these terms and whatever is
remaining here is just there
so
so just copy it here
[Music]
all right now you please note that
this term and
well this term over here they can be
clubbed together
because both of them involve the delta w
del x
and if i do that this uh
so let me just just copy this thing
[Music]
or rather since i have the presence of
these terms
i can maybe skip a step and try to
cancel these out in this in this fashion
so
i'm going to consider this term together
with this term
this term and this term so together
they'll have this del n x del x plus del
n x y del y
which is nothing but 0
next i will have
this term together with
this term you see that is
is going to give me a zero so what i'm
left with
are these terms this one this one
this one and uh this one this one
this and this and note that this
and this is basically the same terms
okay
so uh so in the next step what i can do
is
uh
i'll anyway copy this thing
but i will skip a step
[Music]
let me make this a little bit smaller
so what i'm left with now is
an x uh uh
i think i have missed something very
important
let me just go back here and i need to
note here that
i have actually missed out this rhs okay
so that's very very important
and that's it it's a horrible mistake
i'll correct that immediately
okay so if you just take a look back
on the rhs we have this uh q delta w
so the term that we really need here is
this q
okay so i should be putting not a zero
rather a q here okay so on the
so this these are the terms which are
the coefficients of delta w
this q also is that from the rhs so
ah that's it so major correction here
okay similarly here
there should be a q
[Music]
all right now i have this n x
del square w
[Music]
and x squared
then i have
this one but i'll i'll club this one and
this one
so together i have twice n x y
del square w del x
del y plus
r this n y del square
w del y square
and then i'll have these terms
all right now
this particular combination uh it
it had appeared in uh in our
previous chapter also and uh
if we follow the exact same steps uh
what we are going to
uh obtain is this expression
okay so this and that thing
this and that thing if we if we
if we write in terms of the deflection w
it is going to be
minus d
y harmonic of w okay
so uh overall what we are going to end
up with
is this we have this of course
um
that much
then we have minus d
[Music]
l for w is equal to q
[Music]
and uh
let me put it there for here okay
now what we are going to do is
to uh write this
n x this n x y and this n y
in a very special form not something
which is completely alien to us
but something um something familiar
definitely
but uh in a rather surprising way
so one might wonder what is the
motivation for doing such a thing
so so we'll see the advantages of that
going forward i mean keeping it
in this particular fashion uh i mean
it's absolutely not wrong
but we do want to uh to recast this
equation
in a more convenient form let's put it
that way
so what we're going to say is that
you see this nx is basically coming from
the sigma xx
this n x y is coming from the sigma x y
and this n y
is coming from the sigma y y now
what we have done uh in this
chapter on the one common theory of
plates
uh is exactly the same thing that we had
done back in
our classical plate theory the previous
chapter
and that is by integrating through the
thickness of the plate
from minus h by 2 to h by 2 we had
effect we have effectively reduced what
is
essentially a 3d problem to effectively
a 2d problem
okay that is the the net result of doing
that
integration so we have effectively
reduced it to a two dimensional problem
which is why we are only left
uh to deal with this sigma xx or the
terms in
uh originating from the sigma xx sigma
xy and the sigma yy
now now what is the uh or or
the next step that we're going to follow
uh
has its motivation in that uh
effective two-dimensional reduction
which is to say
that back in applied elasticity
when we were dealing with the 2-d
elastocity chapter
we had expressed the stresses
in terms of a
single scalar function in terms of its
derivatives
using the edit stress function and we
are going to do
uh a thing which is exactly the same so
uh we write this n x and x y and
n y in terms of the scalar function okay
so let me go to the next page
in terms of a scalar function which is
like a stress function
but it is not directly a stress function
because you note that
these are not directly the stresses
rather these are the integrated forms of
the stresses
okay so in terms of a scalar function
capital
f okay so what we say is that
an x is equal to
del square f del y square
and y is equal to del square
f del x square
and n x y
[Music]
is equal to minus del square f
del x del y
so this is a reminiscent of what we had
done in applied elasticity
where we had written sigma xx is equal
to del square
phi del y square sigma yy
is equal to del square phi del x
square and sigma x y
is equal to minus del square phi
del x del y okay so if you do not
remember
uh the discussion around this ad stress
function
i suggest that you take a look back at
that video
uh i'll put a link to that video
uh in the in the
in the details of this particular video
down below
okay uh now with this uh
with this choice uh what we can do is
we can take this equation and rewrite it
in terms of this
scalar function
[Music]
so therefore
this thing becomes del square phi f
del y square del square w
del x square minus
twice l square f
del x del y
del square w del x
del y plus
del square f del x
square del square w del y
square minus
d
by harmonic of w equal to q
all right now uh some of you may be
wondering
that uh because we have now
introduced another unknown uh
is it really true and the unknown is in
the form of this
f uh is it really true that we are we
have
ended up simplifying it or have we
really made it more complicated
but please note that earlier we had this
n x
n y and n x y so those were
unknowns also okay so we had these three
unknowns
but by making this clever choice to
rewrite them in terms of
the scalar function we have kind of made
it more
manageable okay but we really see the
truth about
how manageable it has become or not as
we proceed
but as things stand this particular
equation
does contain two unknowns the first is
the deflection w
which we do not know about and the other
is this unknown scalar function
f okay so we have one equation in our
hand this is a governing differential
equation no doubt
but it contains two unknowns w and f
so it is now the our responsibility
to generate so to speak uh
or to or to determine another governing
differential equation
so that we'll have simultaneously two
equations
and two unknowns so that the system
becomes closed
and we can actually solve for the
unknowns and that will do
in the next video thank you very much